[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute mache ich meinen Mann
zum glücklichsten Mann der Welt.
Denn er hat sich schon ewig eine Maltesers-Torte gewünscht.
Maltesers, das ist diese Süßigkeit hier.
Ich muss sagen, ich kannte die eigentlich
auch lange Zeit gar nicht.
Der Murat hat die dann mal mitgebracht.
Und das sind mit Schokolade überzogene Kekse.
Ich muss natürlich jetzt probieren, um es euch zu zeigen.
Guckt.
In der Mitte sehen die so aus.
Die haben so einen knusprigen
– ja, wie so einen Kekskern und außenrum Schokolade.
Und ich habe jetzt mal die Zutatenliste gelesen.
Und zwar ist es eine Malzfüllung
– wahrscheinlich heißen die deswegen Maltesers –
und Milchschokoladenüberzug,
Gerstenmalzextrakt und so weiter,
Kakaomasse,
Weizen und so weiter.
Ganz am Ende noch Vanilleextrakt.
Wahrscheinlich so wie bei Ela,
so ein Tropfen Vanilleextrakt.
Und deswegen, habe ich mir gedacht,
mache ich jetzt einen Schokobiskuit,
der aber gleich so ein bisschen malzig schmeckt.
Das Ganze will ich dann als Kuppel formen
mit einer leckeren Creme
und auch die Maltesers drin verarbeiten,
im Biskuit jetzt nicht,
aber gleich für den Crunch-Boden und für die Creme.
Dafür nehme ich sechs Eier,
eine Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
jeweils 75 Gramm Kokosblütenzucker
und Zuckerrübensirup,
110 Gramm Mehl
und 40 Gramm Kakao.
Im Prinzip ist das mein Grundrezept für einen Biskuitteig,
nur eben, dass ich statt normalem weißem Zucker
Kokosblütenzucker und Zuckerrübensirup nehme.
Und jetzt gebe ich hier die Zutaten,
also erst mal die zimmerwarmen Eier,
Salz,
Vanilleextrakt
und die beiden Zuckerarten hier in die Rührschüssel
und verrühre das Ganze für mindestens 15 Minuten,
bis alles schön cremig ist.
Und ich denke, dass ich so mit dem Zuckerrübensirup
und mit dem Kokosblütenzucker,
der ja sowieso schon so malzig schmeckt,
einfach echt schon mal
diesen guten Malzgeschmack hinbekomme.
Alternativ könntet ihr auch
meinen lockeren Kuchenboden machen,
der mit Öl und einer Flüssigkeit zubereitet wird,
und könnte da zum Beispiel auch Malzbier benutzen
– also auch alkoholfrei –
und könntet hier dann wirklich
diesen Malzgeschmack auch noch mal reinbringen.
Aber ich glaube, so funktioniert es gut.
Und vor allem, Biskuit ist immer schneller gemacht,
weil er auch schnell backt und wirklich weniger Zutaten hat.
Jetzt lange rühren.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich jetzt das Mehl mit dem Kakao dazu sieben.
Das solltet ihr auch machen,
damit die Klümpchen verschwinden.
Guckt. Weil gerade Kakao hat immer Klümpchen.
[Musik]
So.
Und jetzt wirklich nur vorsichtig unterheben,
bis sich das Mehl mit der Masse verbunden hat.
Und hier nie am Schüsselrand ausklopfen.
Denn ihr habt jetzt so lange
Luft eingeschlagen in die Eiermasse.
Wenn ihr jetzt hier dranklopft,
dann ist die ganze Luft wieder weg.
Das wäre schade.
So.
Den Ofen habe ich bereits vorgeheizt
und habe jetzt hier meinen Backring.
Den habe ich auf 24 cm eingestellt.
Dann kann ich die Masse hier einfüllen,
glatt streichen und sofort im heißen Ofen backen.
Und während der Biskuit backt,
werde ich mich schon mal um die Buttercreme kümmern.
Und es hört sich zwar jetzt sehr buttrig an,
wird es aber nicht.
Und eine Buttercreme schmeckt auch nur nach Butter,
wenn man sie nicht richtig verarbeitet, muss ich sagen.
Und die wird echt lecker,
denn wir machen eine Malteser-Creme.
Ja, eine Malzcreme sozusagen.
[Musik]
Für die Malteser-Creme nehme ich
600 Gramm Milch,
60 Gramm Espresso,
80 Gramm Kokosblütenzucker,
eine Prise Salz,
60 Gramm Speisestärke,
vier Eigelbe
und 100 Gramm Maltesers.
Ich gebe jetzt ein bisschen Milch in den Topf,
erst mal nur ein bisschen.
Den Espresso dazu.
Wer keinen Kaffee mag, tauscht ihn einfach aus durch Milch.
Dann den Zucker.
Salz ist immer ganz wichtig.
Stärke zum Binden.
Die Eigelbe.
Die machen das halt echt schön cremig, muss ich sagen.
Ihr könnt auch einen Pudding ohne Eigelb machen,
aber mit Eigelb schmeckt es schon besser.
Also ich finde einfach, es macht es so ein bisschen cremig.
Aber wenn ihr jetzt sagt: "Nee,
wir wollen eine vegane Buttercreme machen",
könnt ihr auch Pflanzenmilch nehmen
und die Eigelbe wirklich weglassen.
Aber ich finde so ein
– wenn man es nicht unbedingt vegan braucht,
muss man es nicht weglassen.
Jetzt kurz klümpchenfrei verrühren.
Dann die übrige Milch dazu geben
und den Pudding
jetzt schön aufkochen lassen bei mittelhoher Hitze.
Ich mache das immer nie ganz so heiß.
Denn, wenn ihr keine guten Töpfe habt, kann es passieren,
dass dann der Pudding am Boden anbrennt
– das kenne ich noch von früher aus meiner Kindheit –
und vor allem dann der Boden zu heiß wird,
der Rand aber nicht heiß genug wird.
Der Pudding brennt unten an oder auch die Milch
und am Rand kocht er noch nicht mal.
Und jetzt hier mit dem Kupfertopf, muss ich sagen,
oder Gusseisen zum Beispiel wird es gleichmäßig warm.
Aber trotzdem lieber bei mittelhoher Hitze.
Dann nehme ich in der Zwischenzeit die Maltesers
und zerkleinere die.
Den einen Teil gebe ich dann direkt mit rein
und später nehme ich noch mal Maltesers mit der Butter
und werde die dann so ein bisschen crunchy dazu geben.
Aber die, bei denen will ich,
dass die Schokolade in der Creme schmilzt.
Das ist halt immer so ein Glücksspiel.
Ich meine, ich habe die Torte nicht ausprobiert.
Ich habe einfach so aus meinem Biskuit-Grundrezept
und meinem Deutsche-Buttercreme-Grundrezept
einfach so ein Malteser-Rezept gemacht.
Aber ich denke, das wird voll gut.
[Musik]
Den Pudding dann gerne einmal aufkochen lassen.
Und dann gebe ich jetzt
hier die Maltesers rein.
[Musik]
Und dann fülle ich den Pudding jetzt um
in so einen tiefen Emailleteller,
dass er schön abkühlen kann.
Und damit er an der Oberfläche nicht Haut-
– also keine Haut bildet,
werde ich den direkt an der Oberfläche abdecken.
Entweder nehmt ihr eine Frischhaltefolie oder einen Deckel,
der einfach direkt an der Oberfläche abschließt.
[Musik]
Und dann kann ich ihn jetzt schön abkühlen lassen.
Der Biskuit ist jetzt auch gebacken.
Die Stäbchenprobe habe ich gemacht.
Und jetzt löse ich ihn direkt nach dem Backen raus.
[Musik]
Ich ziehe dann drunter die Backfolie weg,
lasse noch kurz den Tortenring drumrum.
Und wenn er, ja, so 20, 30 Minuten abgekühlt ist,
kann ich den Backring entfernen,
ein Tuch noch drüberlegen, damit er nicht austrocknet,
und lasse den und auch die Puddingcreme
jetzt einmal komplett abkühlen.
In der Zwischenzeit
kann ich noch einen Crunch-Boden machen.
Ich finde, die Malteser-Torte sollte
einen Malteser-Crunch-Boden haben.
Oder, Josh?
>> JOSH: Auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Für den Crunch-Boden nehme ich
200 Gramm Maltesers,
nehme 50 Gramm gehackte Mandeln
und 50 Gramm Butter.
Ich hoffe, es passt so vom Mengenverhältnis her.
Ich mache es jetzt so, dass ich die Mandeln
in einer Pfanne röste,
damit sie einfach so ein schönes Röstaroma bekommen.
Dann kann ich hier die Maltesers wieder zerkleinern.
[Musik]
Der Rasenmäher springt nicht an.
Ich glaube, viele wissen nicht mal, was ich meine.
Aber in meiner Kindheit gab es noch Rasenmäher,
die hat man so angemacht.
Dann kann ich mir schon mal einen Tortenretter nehmen,
eine Backfolie
und einen sauberen Tortenring mit 24 cm Durchmesser.
So werde ich nämlich gleich
diesen No-Bake-Boden zubereiten.
Und sobald die Mandeln so eine schöne Farbe bekommen,
– man riecht es auch dann immer ganz gut,
weil sie dann eben schön lecker duften –
dann schalte ich den Herd aus.
Jetzt kann ich den Herd ausmachen,
die Butter dazu geben.
Die schmilzt ja dann einfach durch die Restwärme.
Ich sage es euch: Wenn Butter gesund wäre,
wäre ich Fitness-Bloggerin.
Es ist so.
Quark, Butter
– Quark ist ja echt gut, aber die Butter, die killt es halt immer.
Und, okay, der Zucker vielleicht.
Dann gebe ich noch die Maltesers dazu.
Da schmilzt dann auch die Schokolade in der Restwärme.
Ich hoffe, das passt jetzt vom Verhältnis her,
dass der Boden gut wird.
[Musik]
Wisst ihr was? Damit es ein bisschen schokoladiger wird,
gebe ich noch einen Esslöffel Kakao dazu.
Der ist mir nämlich ein bisschen zu hell, der Boden,
muss ich sagen.
Komm, Josh. Wir gehen an den schönen Backschrank.
Ach, ich lasse ihn offen. Der ist so schön.
Jetzt einen Esslöffel davon hier rein.
Oh yes!
[Musik]
Und dann direkt hier reinfüllen,
verstreichen und glatt drücken.
Und dann kann der No-Bake-Boden auch in den Kühlschrank.
Und ich denke, dass mittlerweile der Biskuit gut abgekühlt ist,
die Puddingcreme gut abgekühlt ist,
sodass ich gleich mit der Buttercreme weitermachen kann.
Okay, das ist so weich und smooth,
da brauche ich nicht mal eine Burgerpresse.
Das kann ich einfach verstreichen.
[Musik]
Jetzt stelle ich die Torte fertig.
Erst mal die Buttercreme.
Dafür brauche ich jetzt noch 450 Gramm weiche Butter,
50 Gramm Puderzucker
und 50 Gramm Maltesers.
Jetzt kommt zuerst die weiche Butter hier rein.
Es sieht nach sehr viel Butter aus.
Okay, es ist viel Butter.
Aber bedenkt, dass im Biskuit gar kein Fett ist.
Das heißt, das gleicht es schon wieder aus.
Dann der Puderzucker.
Das schön cremig rühren.
Also es darf schon so fünf bis zehn Minuten rühren.
Die Maltesers werde ich wieder zerkleinern.
Das mache ich gleich,
werde aber zuerst einmal den Biskuit durchschneiden
und zwar zweimal durchschneiden,
sodass drei gleichmäßige Böden entstehen.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann die Torte zusammengesetzt werden.
Hier habe ich den Crunch-Boden.
Da löse ich schon mal das Backpapier drunter weg.
Wenn ihr jetzt eine Torte machen wollte, die keine Kugel ist,
könnt ihr den Tortenring drumrum lassen.
Aber ich löse ihn ab.
Denn bei mir wird es eine Kuppel.
So. Immer schön alles wegräumen.
Dann habt ihr eine schöne saubere Fläche.
Und jetzt
– ups.
Und jetzt nehme ich ein bisschen Creme,
streiche sie hier drauf.
[Musik]
Josh, von einer Skala von 1 bis 10
wie lecker wird die Torte?
>> JOSH: 11!
>> SALLY: Yay!
Also ein bisschen Creme.
>> JOSH: Die wird anders lecker.
>> SALLY: Die wird anders lecker.
Und die wird so was von anders lecker!
Und jetzt vergesst ihr alles,
was ich euch bisher beigebracht habe
beim Glattstreichen der Torten.
Denn wir wollen eine Kuppel, wollen keine gerade Fläche.
Deswegen streicht die Creme kuppelförmig auf.
Ja,
es ist
– meine Hand will immer glatt.
Aber no, no, no!
Wir wollen eine Kuppeltorte.
[Musik]
Das sieht so falsch aus.
Also wie bei einem Maulwurfkuchen.
Und hier auch schon direkt
den Rand so ein bisschen mit bestreichen.
Und guckt mal, die Buttercreme hat jetzt echt
die perfekte Konsistenz.
Falls ihr diese Torte im Sommer zum Beispiel
zubereiten solltet
und die Außentemperatur sehr warm ist,
dann stellt die Buttercreme gern auch mal zwischendurch kühl.
Aber so bei Raumtemperatur hat sie
eben eine schöne streichfähige Konsistenz.
Und das ist schon wichtig,
weil man sonst nicht mit ihr arbeiten kann.
Beim letzten ist es ein bisschen schwierig,
weil der natürlich auf der Oberfläche
nicht so weich ist wie der mittlere.
Aber ihr könnt ihn einfach ein bisschen drücken.
Oder den unten rein wäre besser gewesen
und den mittleren obendrauf.
Macht es bitte so rum,
der mittlere obendrauf.
Der ist nämlich schön weich und noch anschmiegsamer.
Weil die Kuppel wird ja im Prinzip immer kuppelförmiger
und dann ist es einfacher.
Aber hier geht es auch.
Der reißt oben ein bisschen ein, das macht aber gar nichts.
Das darf so.
So, noch mal Creme.
Ein bisschen was lasse ich mir dann übrig
fürs Ende zum Glattstreichen.
So ungefähr.
Ja, so ungefähr 100 Gramm.
[Musik]
Und, guckt mal, mit so einer flexiblen Teigkarte dann
gerne noch so ein bisschen am Rand hochstreichen.
Da könnt ihr nämlich auch ganz gut
hier die ganze Buttercreme am Rand so säubern.
Okay.
Ich wollte sagen, wir machen eine Iglutorte, wenn es schneit.
[Musik]
Weißt, aber zu meiner Verteidigung,
nach Januar ist für mich der Winter vorbei,
weil nach Weihnachten.
Aber eigentlich kommt ja dann immer erst der richtige Winter.
Die Torte ist für mich jetzt erst mal schön.
Die kommt jetzt in den Kühlschrank,
wenn es schneller gehen soll, ins Gefrierfach.
Und ich habe jetzt 100 Gramm Creme noch übrig.
Die werde ich gleich mit 100 Gramm
geschmolzener Zartbitterschokolade verrühren,
zum einen, damit sie dunkler wird,
und zum anderen, damit sie eine festere Konsistenz bekommt.
Denn dann kommt die im Prinzip obendrauf
und die schimmert ja auch so ein bisschen durch.
Das heißt, die muss schon noch dunkler werden,
damit die Maltesers drauf passen.
Also kühl stellen.
Hier noch 100 Gramm Zartbitterschokolade erwärmen,
verrühren und dann geht es gleich weiter.
[Musik]
Diese Schokoladencreme streiche ich jetzt hier darüber.
Und ich finde, farblich passt sie jetzt perfekt.
Und sie schmeckt auch gut.
[Musik]
Und da die Torte jetzt so ein bisschen angefroren ist,
kann man es auch echt super verteilen.
Dann wird ja auch diese Buttercreme gleich schön fest.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr es jetzt ganz perfekt machen wollt,
nehmt ihr ein Stück Tortenrandfolie.
Ihr könnt aber auch einen Joghurteimer nehmen
und einfach den Rand wegschneiden.
So ein bisschen dickere Folie einfach nur nehmen
und dann
hier
glatt ziehen.
[Musik]
Es war vorher schon glatt, aber jetzt ist es wirklich anders glatt.
Aber das muss man halt echt machen,
bevor die Creme anfängt, fest zu werden.
Wenn sie zu
– das ist jetzt grenzwertig.
Jetzt muss ich aufhören.
Und jetzt setze ich die Torte
auf meine Tortenplatte.
Wir ignorieren, dass sie mir fast hier runtergefallen wäre.
Wir ignorieren es einfach.
Ich habe nämlich kurz vergessen, dass ich
diesen Keksboden drunter habe.
Und der klebt ja nicht.
Und dann dachte ich, der Biskuit klebt,
und dann voll mit Schwung hoch.
>> JOSH: Upsi.
>> SALLY: Upsi!
Hach, schön!
Und jetzt kurz die Hände schön sauber machen.
Und jetzt werden die Maltesers drumrum geklebt.
Ich werde mir jetzt aber noch die Mitte markieren.
[Musik]
Und ich meine, ich finde es jetzt schon heftig,
dass jetzt so viele draufkommen.
Aber für die Optik halt schon,
ist es schon gut.
Und ich fange jetzt einfach hier unten an,
setze erst mal die Linie voll
und dann die komplette Torte.
Ich sehe jetzt schon
– huch!
Die fallen wieder runter,
weil die Buttercreme einfach schon zu fest ist.
Das heißt, ich werde jetzt einfach
ein bisschen Vollmilchschokolade schmelzen,
die immer so leicht eintunken und dann kleben.
Und dann müsste es gehen.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: Danke.
Die Torte ist auch nicht schlecht.
>> MURAT: Du bist schon eine kleine Traumfrau, gell?
Weißt du das?
>> SALLY: Eine große.
>> MURAT: Ja, eine große Traumfrau.
Hör auf, dich jetzt groß zu machen. Ich sage es dir.
So.
>> SALLY: Ich mache mich nicht groß.
Du hast hohe Schuhe an.
>> MURAT: Aber eine coole Geschichte, gell?
>> SALLY: Ich habe Crocs an.
>> MURAT: Du kriegst alles hin.
>> SALLY: Er hat so Absätze.
>> MURAT: Nein, habe ich nicht. Stimmt doch gar nicht.
Sie lügt. Glaubt ihr nicht.
>> SALLY: Sieht schon cool aus, gell?
>> MURAT: Traue keiner Frau mit einem Messer in der Hand.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Sieht cool aus, oder?
>> MURAT: Hm.
Ich finde auch das macht das, die Torte
so besonders und ist sofort ein Eyecatcher.
Was es aber auch macht, ist
>> SALLY: Teuer.
>> MURAT: teuer.
Wirklich.
Das Ding ist echt nicht günstig, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Weil die echt so teuer sind
und wir keine mehr hatten,
haben wir die Packung mit einer Zitrone gefüllt.
>> MURAT: Ja. Aber ehrlich, das ist ja...
Merkt ihr das?
So wird es im Fernsehen gemacht, mal schön beschissen,
sogar an einem letzten Malteser noch gespart.
Und ich bin auch
– eigentlich bin ich auch froh, dass das nicht zu günstig ist,
weil sonst würde man sich leicht mal überfressen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich muss dazu sagen, ich finde die Optik Hammer.
>> SALLY: Wobei es ein bisschen unsatisfying ist,
dass die Maltesers nicht perfekt gleich groß sind
und ich manchmal Lücken habe.
Aber egal, das sei mal dahingestellt.
>> MURAT: Und wenn ihr jetzt immer noch schreibt,
das ist nicht von Nestlé übrigens.
Das ist von den anderen Ganoven. Genau.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und, was man machen kann
– also ich denke, geschmacklich ist sie schon top.
Aber mir persönlich,
ich als Sally, die eh sowieso nicht so viel Süßes isst,
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: mir sind es zu viel Maltesers außenrum.
>> MURAT: Und ich, Murat, der so gern Süßes isst,
für mich kann es gar nicht genug sein. Ja.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber...
>> MURAT: Wie viele Euro,
wie viele Packungen waren das jetzt? Sei mal ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Sechs oder acht.
>> MURAT: O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Weil allein die Deko waren fünf.
>> MURAT: Sechs oder acht...
Und dann hast du die innen drin auch noch mal gefüllt?
>> SALLY: Ja, der Crunch-Boden
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: und dann noch in der Buttercreme.
>> MURAT: Hm. Ich weiß ganz genau,
am Montag, sehe ich schon,
kommt eine Ad-hoc-Meldung raus von Malteser:
"Umsatzwachstum im dritten Quartal um 700 Prozent".
Durch deine Torte.
>> SALLY: Wir sind im ersten Quartal.
>> MURAT: Ja. Übrigens, wie gesagt,
keine Produktplatzierung.
Ihr könnt auch was anderes nehmen.
Ihr könnt auch Rocher-Torten
– -Kugeln nehmen, aber es wird dadurch nicht billiger.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Was ihr aber auch machen könnt, wenn ihr sagt,
ihr wollt die Maltesers-Torte geschmacklich
auch nachmachen, aber nicht so viele außenrum:
Dann bestreut doch die glatt gestrichene Torte,
bestreut sie mit Kakao,
so richtig schön matt,
und klebt nur so drei Reihen Maltesers unten hin.
>> MURAT: Ja, könnt ihr auch machen.
Das wäre die billige Variante.
>> SALLY: Aber ich muss sagen, die Torte
ist von der Zubereitung her nicht zu aufwendig.
Also klar,
das Drankleben hat mich jetzt schon Nerven gekostet,
muss ich sagen, weil es eigentlich so lange gedauert hat,
wie die Torte an sich zu backen.
Aber so, muss ich sagen, kein Werkzeug, nichts Aufwändiges.
Es ist halt nur...
>> MURAT: Also es kann wirklich jeder machen auch.
Es kann jeder Güni nachmachen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Oh, Schatz, nicht so ein großes Stück!
Hey, übertreib nicht!
>> SALLY: Nein, aber ich muss doch
>> MURAT: Ach so.
>> SALLY: kurz fürs Foto.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich denke doch immer schon...
>> MURAT: Die Menschen denken ja:
"Was ich mit dem Typ los? Hat der noch nie Ding?"
>> SALLY: Ich denke doch schon fürs Foto mit.
Okay, Anschnitt ist halt echt schwierig.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Willst du dann nicht so eine Torten-
>> SALLY: Ich würde gern das so...
>> MURAT: Palette?
>> SALLY: Woah! Woah, ich weiß, was ich nehme!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Endlich.
>> MURAT: Jetzt mal eine neue Produktplatzierung:
Sallys
– was ist das von Sallys?
>> SALLY: Palette.
>> MURAT: Hamburger-Palette,
Rausnehm-Dingsbums.
Ja.
Oder ein Lada-Wagenheber.
>> SALLY: Woah!
>> MURAT: Krass.
>> SALLY: Ist das der Hammer?
>> MURAT: Darf ich mal sehen?
Boah!
Woah!
So.
Liebe Grüße gehen raus an den Adipositas Verband Passau.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich würde mal gern googeln. Gibt es den überhaupt?
>> MURAT: Aber, wie gesagt, man isst so was nicht täglich.
So was isst man ja wirklich vielleicht alle zwei Wochen mal.
Ja.
Maximum.
Ich zumindest.
Leute, ich wäre...
Weißt du was? Weißt du, was auch schön gewesen wäre?
Wenn du einfach eine Fitness-Bloggerin gewesen wärst.
>> SALLY: Ich habe gesagt heute...
>> MURAT: Weißt du, wie ich dann aussehen würde?
>> MURAT: Ich wäre voll die Maschine wahrscheinlich.
>> SALLY: Habe ich das heute gesagt?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich habe heute gesagt, wenn Butter gesund wäre,
wäre ich die perfekte Fitness-Bloggerin.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Du hast jetzt nur Buttercreme probiert.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich wollte...
Darf ich meine ehrliche Meinung sagen,
ohne dass du sauer bist?
>> SALLY: Sag.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ja.
Hey, ich finde das ein bisschen zu buttrig,
muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Darf ich das sagen?
>> SALLY: Jetzt probier es doch mal im Ganzen.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich probiere es. Ich probiere es jetzt.
Aber ich fand das echt zu buttrig gerade.
>> SALLY: Boah, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das schneiden soll.
>> MURAT: Kann das gerade sein,
dass ich gerade ein halbes Kilo Kerrygold im Mund hatte?
>> SALLY: Nee, es war die günstige Butter.
>> MURAT: Echt?
War es die Markenbutter, die Deutsche Markenbutter?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Oh!
>> SALLY: Okay, im Schnitt alles
zerstört.
Es geht ja nur um den Effekt.
>> MURAT: War das gerade ein Effekt?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: War aber auch sehr elegant mit Liebe.
Kann das sein?
Du hättest mich einfach nur beleidigen können.
Du hättest die Torte nicht zusammenschneiden müssen.
So. Ich probiere es jetzt aus, okay?
>> SALLY: Ich finde, das ist die perfekte Torte,
um draußen Smash Cake zu machen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Smash Potato, Smash Cake.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Oh! Hast du es mit dem Boden probiert?
>> MURAT: Mhm.
>> SALLY: Uff!
Probier es.
Probier es mit dem Crunch-Boden bitte.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Ich weiß, dass es Menschen gibt, die auf so was stehen.
100 Prozent.
Ich finde es fast so ein bisschen zu buttrig.
>> MURAT: Kann man da was machen?
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Es waren nur 450 Gramm Butter.
>> MURAT: Ehrlich jetzt?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Waren das 450 Gramm Butter?
>> MURAT: Deutsche Markenbutter?
>> SALLY: Ja. Aber 600 Gramm Milch.
>> MURAT: Oder war es die aus Schleswig-Holstein?
Wie hießt die?
>> SALLY: Alsan.
>> MURAT: Alsan.
>> SALLY: Ich liebe es.
>> MURAT: Ehrlich?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Geschmackssache, aber...
>> SALLY: Also es sieht nicht so aus,
als hätte ich zu viel Butter in meinem Leben gegessen.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Ich finde es echt ein bisschen zu viel Butter.
Was für eine Creme könnte man noch machen?
>> SALLY: Die war halt im Angebot.
>> MURAT: Welche? Die Butter oder die Creme?
>> SALLY: Die Markenbutter.
>> MURAT: Echt?
>> SALLY: Ha ja.
Da habe ich gedacht, wenn die Maltesers schon so teuer sind.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Also ein bisschen weniger Butter, geht das?
>> SALLY: Mhm.
>> MURAT: Dir schmeckt das, gell?
>> SALLY: Ich liebe es.
Warte. Ich will, dass Josh probiert,
weil der Josh
eigentlich nicht so krass der Tortenfreak ist, gell?
>> JOSH: Nee, gar nicht.
>> MURAT: Aber du bist ehrlich, Josh, gell?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Josh ist immer ehrlich, manchmal zu ehrlich.
>> MURAT: Weil ich fand das echt ein bisschen zu buttrig.
Wirklich.
>> SALLY: Manchmal meint es der Josh
zu gut mit seiner Ehrlichkeit, dann disst er mich einfach.
>> MURAT: Obwohl, vergiss, du hast einen Arbeitsvertrag.
>> JOSH: Ja, ja.
>> MURAT: Sag jetzt nichts Falsches, gell?
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Der hat schon seine dritte Abmahnung gekriegt.
>> MURAT: Sei voll ehrlich.
Man kann es ja auch mal sagen, wenn man nicht...
Wir haben alle Kündigungsschutz.
>> SALLY: Komm.
>> MURAT: Ich meine, ihr könnt abhauen.
Ich bin mit ihr verheiratet.
>> JOSH: So einen leicht buttrigen Belag.
>> MURAT: Gell? Ein bisschen buttrig schon, gell?
>> SALLY: Halt! Das ist Sarahs Stück.
>> JOSH: Aber...
Aber es ist lecker.
>> MURAT: Lecker, gell?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SARAH: Ist da Boden?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Mit Boden, mit Crunch-Boden.
Ich kriege Sarah immer durch Crunch-Boden.
>> MURAT: Es ist jetzt echt nicht schlecht. Ganz ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Man könnte es auch
mit 100 Gramm weniger Butter machen.
>> MURAT: Dann macht 100 Gramm weniger Butter rein.
Dann habt ihr trotzdem noch ein halbes Kilo drin,
aber dann ist es nicht so schlimm.
>> SALLY: Man hätte das Ganze
natürlich auch mit einer Sahnecreme
wie bei einem Maulwurfkuchen machen können.
Aber
– und das ist der Grund,
warum ich eine Buttercreme gewählt habe –
ich muss ja diese Kuppel sozusagen schön glatt kriegen
– ihr habt es ja gesehen so mit dieser Folie –
und dann diese Maltesers drankleben.
Und das geht halt nicht,
wenn ihr so eine Quarksahne drunter habt.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Das hält halt nicht.
Das heißt, so eine Buttercreme ist schon
– hat immer ihre Daseinsberechtigung.
Und ich finde es lecker.
>> MURAT: Okay.
100 Gramm weniger Butter.
Macht's gut!
>> SALLY: Gönn dir die Butter.
>> MURAT: Es war recht schön.
Grüße gehen raus an Rügenwalder
– Malteser
– nee,
SanLucar Zitronen.
Macht's gut!
>> SALLY: Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
>> MURAT: Tschau!
>> SALLY: Bis zum nächsten Mal!
>> MURAT: War mir eine Ehre.
Ich gehe jetzt auf die Bühne
– nicht auf die Bühne, auf die Baustelle.
Bis dann! Tschau!
Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh, ich liebe es!
>> MURAT: War cool, war echt gut.
>> SALLY: Ich liebe es und ich finde, man schmeckt
das Malzige raus von den Maltesers.
>> MURAT: Man könnte meinen,
die hättest du schon mal gemacht.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ich habe jetzt kurz nachgedacht
und habe mir gedacht, wenn Murat sagt, das ist zu viel Butter,
hole ich jetzt den Buttercremetorteexperten rein,
Siamak.
[Applaus]
Wuh!
>> SARAH: Wuh!
>> SALLY: Siamak, ich habe eine Torte gemacht.
>> SIAMAK: Mit Buttercreme.
>> SALLY: Der Boden – woah, der ist der Wahnsinn!
Kennst du Maltesers?
>> SIAMAK: Ich habe es schon mal gehört,
aber, glaube ich, noch nie probiert.
>> SALLY: Die sind echt gut.
>> SIAMAK: Ist das Keks so innen drin?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SIAMAK: Ah ja.
>> SALLY: Probier mal.
>> SIAMAK: Ja, mache ich.
Also es gibt eigentlich nie zu viel Buttercreme
meiner Meinung nach.
>> SALLY: Ja, Murat sagt halt, das ist ihm zu buttrig.
Also ich mag es.
[Musik]
>> SIAMAK: Oh, der Boden kommt voll gut aber.
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Der Boden, ich finde den Boden auch Hammer.
>> SIAMAK: Weil hier oben ist er so weich und dann unten
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SIAMAK: so knusprig.
Ich nehme jetzt nur die Buttercreme mal.
>> SALLY: Woah!
>> SIAMAK: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Murat,
der Siamak gönnt sich einen Löffel Buttercreme.
>> SIAMAK: Gar nicht zu viel.
>> SALLY: Gell, oder?
>> SIAMAK: Mhm.
>> SALLY: Ich würde mir auch so eine Buttercreme
einfach aufs Brot schmieren morgens.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
Wie so Mousse.
>> SALLY: Woah!
So ein Löffeldessert einfach Buttercreme.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Oder? So als Buttercremeliebhaber?
>> SIAMAK: Top!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich finde es aber... Ja?
Hm?
>> SIAMAK: Jetzt eigentlich noch Fondant hinten dran,
>> SALLY: O Gott! Okay, da bin ich raus.
>> SIAMAK: dazwischen noch mal Buttercreme.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Du bist halt echt Hardcore-Buttercreme.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich muss sagen,
so geschmacklich finde ich den Boden krass.
Dann Buttercreme, Biskuit,
ich glaube, so die Hälfte der Höhe
wäre für mich geschmacklich optimal.
Aber so ist es halt optisch schon ein Highlight.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Mir sind auch ein bisschen
zu viele Maltesers außenrum, aber egal.
>> SIAMAK: Oh!
>> SALLY: So die halbe Tüte.
>> SIAMAK: Weißt du, was auch cool wäre?
Wenn man den Boden noch mal dazwischen macht.
>> SALLY: O ja!
>> SIAMAK: Das wäre, glaube ich, auch saucool.
>> SALLY: Dann ist der Anschnitt so ein bisschen schwierig,
weil dann drückst du es
>> SIAMAK: Hm, stimmt.
>> SALLY: ganz flach, aber so an sich
– oh! Oder machen und dann reinbröseln.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
Weil der Boden, der ist echt gut.
>> SALLY: Also ihr seht schon,
das war die Maltesers-Torte, die optisch cool aussieht,
und dann machen wir noch eine Maltesers-Torte,
die geschmacklich on point wird.
Versprochen.
Danke, Siamak. Ich wusste,
>> SIAMAK: Ja, gerne.
>> SALLY: es wird jemand kommen, der Buttercreme liebt.
>> SIAMAK: Ja, Buttercreme geht immer.
Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Gerne.
[Musik]